what to do
with realization
of emptiness
of open space
is Eros
is Tantra
it's weaving the realization of open
spacious
compassionate love
into the creative Cosmic ties of
existence
it's holding loving transformative space
for
those that earnestly desire
transformation
it's pretty obvious
so there's a strong
seeking impulse that comes
and
there's the desire to know what one is
to know what reality is to know what
truth is
and so
we
can use this analogy of an amusement
park where
where in the amusement park and we're
trying to find
what is the source of the amusement park
and so we're looking around for the
source of the amusement park everywhere
trying to find something that brings us
lasting peace happiness well-being Joy
love
and the ironic thing as always is that
we are literally carrying
the answer
as the pupil
the pupil itself is
empty space
it is emptiness
it is the aperture it is the uncreated
it is the unmanifest it is non-being it
is non-existence that's you
and it's
looking at perceiving exploring
experiencing being existence
so right there you transcend The Duality
between the two
into non-dual
where the subject object collapses
the self other collapses
the god human collapses
all of those dualities collapse
and so in this analogy of the amusement
park
we don't
find some transcendent
Escape
that exits us and removes us permanently
from the amusement park and never go
back to it
because that's not non-dual
that's not integration
once you realize
the empty spacious open nature of mind
of what you truly are
you weave the realization back into the
amusement park
you hold the loving transformative space
for all of yourself in the amusement
park
true Eros
true love
true openness
just like the loving transformative
space was held for you
in your process in my process
that's love
that's non-duality
that's Tantra
emptiness equals arrows
or zeros
equals arrows
so Eros with a z at the beginning zeros
and it makes perfect sense
because
when we initially felt that suffering
within ourselves and that seeking
impulse
we oriented ourselves towards truth
and towards service to others or sdo
rather than service to self
and so the ultimate expression
of service to others
at the end of the path
upon realizing
open space
is obviously Eros
the ultimate expression
of service to others
is Eros
it's to be empty love
space
four
earnest
transformational desire
yes